ну щасливий, і мені вже казали
все ще не оптимістично, але
інтереси, які я хотів би сказати тут
вони великі
наше національне ні не можна розглядати окремо
стає частиною міжнародної реальності
договір спрямований на україну
підтримкою росту настільки ж стабільною
демократія на східному кордоні європи
якщо договір про асоціацію не набере чинності
вступає в силу
підвищує ризик нестабільності
регіон
крім того, виникає потреба
поділу в Європі
по відношенню до Росії і саме до нас
найкращою відповіддю є одностайність
Зовнішня політика Росії
призводить до дестабілізації Європи
Я роблю кордони в інтересах країни
звернення до раціональних сил
в Нідерландах для можливості a
рішення підтримки
це набагато більше, ніж одні нідерланди
ми також більші як країна
частиною більш широкого міжнар
боротьба громади як фронт
за стабільність і наші кордони і
проти агресії у світі
ми теж до останньої хвилини
всю нашу енергію, щоб знайти рішення
знайти
швидше за все, він ще там
на цьому етапі, якщо нічого не зміниться
ми не можемо нічого робити, крім понеділка
оголосити, що ми відхиляємо зняття
відправити в кімнату